[Music]
with all these expensive weddings comes
a lot of wedding advice
and a lot of that advice happens to be
on the internet and a portion of that
internet is tick tock rachel and i know
you have some feelings about tick tock
but there's a specific video that i
wanted to show you i wanted to watch
together as a family and i wanted to get
your reaction are you okay with this i
can't wait okay here is some of the
worst wedding advice i've heard okay
let's go so i wanted to share with you
the best wedding advice
of all time the second that you get
engaged
open a credit card
now i know what you're gonna say i
already have a credit card
get a new one get one that's running a
promotion but what you're gonna do is
you're gonna put every single wedding
expense you ever have on that card even
if the vendor charges like a two percent
credit card fee pay the fee it is worth
it seriously um we got a ton of bonus
points we put everything on that card
because we already have cash saved
and so i think a lot of people think
like well let's just pay with cash then
we're not in debt right but you already
have the cash so we just use it to pay
off the credit card every month
but we're still getting miles and that's
like where the money really is so then
when you have all of these miles you use
it to literally book the honeymoon of
your dreams for free
okay oh there's so much there to unpack
rachel we could we could sit here all
day i know but it's the mindset that is
so it's a mindset that's a good point
that's so normal this is the normal
culture most people listening and
watching go i don't get it what was
wrong with that that advice that's true
yep yeah use the points go on the free
vacation
it's all working out all gonna work out
even if you have the cash that'd be okay
that was the wildest part they've got
the cash to do it apparently and she
says even though you have the cash put
on the card
here's the thing
this and this is tried and true it's
always been true
because there's been study after study
after study that when you choose to
spend someone else's money
naturally you are going to spend more
because there is not an emotional
connection to the money you're spending
so as you're planning this wedding and
putting everything on the credit card
you're like well yeah yeah yeah let's do
that or the you know that dress the
dress it's like
800 more it'll be fine because we're
gonna get the points
you start to justify
you really do these these transactions
and the expenses and
and doing a little bit more is actually
better i'd rather spend more because i'm
going to get the airline miles on the
back end so it's going to be fine and
the crazy thing is when you look
especially a wedding budget the average
wedding is 34 000
and you give yourself any leeway
emotionally to say oh we can we can
spend a little bit more
how much more thousands and thousands
and thousands that you're probably going
to spend again because there's just not
that am there's not a feeling of okay
that's my money leaving so you are
to get a plane ticket to cancun and i'm
like listen plain it's expensive right
now i get it sure
but but it's not thousands let's just
say a thousand let's say let's say it's
five hundred dollars there five hundred
dollars okay two people it's two
thousand dollars i guarantee you they
spent more than two thousand dollars
because of the idea okay well we're
gonna we're gonna get some on the back
end oh yeah
and then my other can i just go one more
journal please oh i know everyone's like
uh and this doesn't i don't feel this
way this is how i this is one of the
reasons i really just don't like i don't
like the whole industry of credit cards
because in order to get those miles in
order to get those points it's not
because
mastercard is like this generous you
know
and they're like you know what you've
been just so great so i'm gonna just
give you
give you something
they have trillions of dollar like
billions billions
i'm going to say trillions i don't know
that's true but billions we can say for
sure
of dollars for people that don't pay
their credit cards off and are paying
interest so the people that are
mismanaging their money you get to go
get your seven hundred dollar plane
ticket paid for by and i'm like it's
gross it doesn't feel good it does well
to me i'm like you know what the whole
end gross can i just use my money and
like stay away from like i don't even
want to participate i don't want to
participate so you're part of that
system i don't like it i don't like it
wow well we dug into this on the fine
print podcast that we did and we
interviewed an ex-employee at capital
one who was overseeing one of these
programs and here's what she told me the
average credit card has 30 different
price point and reward tiers and that's
on purpose they want it to be confusing
and overwhelming and they do 10 000
experiments that's a direct number she
told me on customers
you are a hamster in the maze and you
get to the cheese and you think i won i
won i got airline miles i won and then
you zoom out and you're a hamster in the
maze
on the wheel in the cycle of trying to
get more points to go on your next trip
and i just go dude become your own cash
back program save up for your trip i'll
teach you how to budget we can do this
on our own and not have to hope for some
miles to come through and the fact that
she said and you get those airline miles
and that's where the money really is and
i'm like your airline miles are worth
zero dollars
you can't cash those out yeah yeah you
can cash money out of your bank but your
airline miles a hundred thousand miles
we don't where does that get you that's
not a hundred thousand miles of travel
that's an arbitrary number
that these credit card companies use to
confuse you yeah yeah if they were so
generous they would just say all right
two percent it's gonna be full cash back
here's two thousand dollars they make it
confusing on purpose to get you to spend
and spend and spend to spend more and
more don't do this and only 48 of
americans so
you know a little less than half
pay off their credit card every month so
you hear people say you know well i
might have yeah half of those people
that say that
that's the problem with advice like this
is she's saying a blanket because i can
manage my credit card spending well
everyone should go get a credit card and
then half of america is in credit card
debt average 68 000 i'm sorry 6 800
dollars
so almost 700 dollars seven i'm sorry
gosh seven thousand dollars
and and i'm like you know and the credit
card
arguments because i'm like the math like
okay get it like sure yeah you spend
that you get okay then yes
on the on the sheet of paper i'm like
yes that that that but again what you
don't take into account is everything
else we've been talking about of how
much more you're spending how much
you're just in at their rat race of them
knowing you better than you even know
yourself
um and it's and then you know and i know
some people use their credit card to
make ends meet they literally do not
make enough
to
live and so that's one reason they use
which we would say hey
you've got to cut expenses and you have
to earn extra money you can't con
continue to live in the negatives
and win long term yes
and then the other is just buying a
bunch of stuff i'm like and then you end
up with almost a seven thousand dollar
balance on hours for people and i'm like
and it's and i think about our the
minimalists some of our friends i'm like
it is it's just it's just this american
standard
of what we expect to live like
and we don't expect to live like this
we're going to do anything in our means
possible because this is the expectation
i'm like who set the bar who decided
that the credit card companies did
and here's the truth you can't spend
your way into a meaningful life
no and you sit there with your credit
card and you spend look at your
transactions how many of those were
wants versus needs don't tell me you
only spent it on gas
listen you're having some fun and that's
okay but that stuff's gonna have you if
you're not careful and you're gonna be
sitting there with credit card debt
hoping for some airline miles so that
you can go to cancun pay for your own
dang honeymoon we'll teach you how we
can do this all day long dude you don't
have to wait on capital one